citizens of the reject Nation we are
going to watch the penultimate episode
for Cobra Kai season five John how are
you I am I'm good I'm a little you know
not ready but I'm good
how are you
don't need all the word vomit uh Andrew
how are you I am doing well thank you I
am uh well balanced and I'm strong in
root like Bonsai it happened to people
just saying I'm good how are you girl
I'm fine look at look how look how
efficient oh that was good
leave a like Jesus
right now uh leave a like and get this
get this over with
subscribe hit the notifications where
you guys made us waste too much time
with your
introspective answers here patreon
how is my day the team of prepper yeah
yeah they know it really by this point
they've heard it
[Music]
you knew all along that silver cheated
at the all Valley and you did nothing
you don't know what it's like in there
what I've had to deal with
oh my God your family has suffered
because of you that's enough
she didn't do a priest this whole time
what hit her Robbie
I knew this was a mistake
Tori Santa what did she tell you don't
let this affect your friendship wow
it's Robbie I never went to the
appointments
I didn't realize what it'd be like to
see how our kid starts out
he's perfect or she or whatever your
child wants to identify as yeah Johnny
you should wait got a ways to go
Lord's day is uh sounds good oh
Mr Lawrence
I've never seen some people bump into
each other in Los Angeles well Los
Angeles is a very small place we live in
it we know
but you and your partner have
accomplished as a joy if you get to
experience
tell you about the baby
I was talking about you and marusso
Landing her coveted spot in the Sakai
taikai but
apparently there's lots of celebrate no
save every moment
before it's gone
planned
to be on the floor below like I said
perfect timing I'm sure Carmen would
love to help me finish an entire by la
tequila yeah in her State not a good
idea yes always good to have clear
minded case
Johnny uh are you saying what we think
you're saying
carbon's pregnant
come on hey anush we're going out you
win we're gonna celebrate Johnny knocked
up his girl oh as much as I'd love to
celebrate the guy who punched me in the
gut at work I have a date
and uh congrats on procreating
it's ref and Stingray are and Silver's
payroll they'll never admit to anything
Stingray is still my friend he wouldn't
lie to me
at least I hope he would do you think
you can get him to talk
find out where he lives After Five
Seasons that guy's gonna have a clock
last night let's not get into it right
now
season six
his hair is growing every episode I told
you man Miguel scissor ants they'll all
pay for that little stunt they pulled
with this okay
they are mosquitoes
the next time an unwanted pest lands on
our arm
we will swap them
[Music]
don't bloody
I came here to apologize
I didn't understand at the time but I
realized now I was wrong
I shouldn't have just left
should have taken you all with me
oh there is pain in this dojo and it's
built upon fear because this man is not
your sense hey he is your enemy
but it's not too late for you you're not
past the point of no return there's
still another way
can you open your jacket to me
there's our Matrix reference I
appreciate how committed you are to
protecting this but as your friend I am
giving you permission to take a break
tonight all right seriously what's your
poison
wrong guy then I stinks ah my man one
wrong move and you could be killed
or have you already made that move
yep
you lied to the court
and you lied to my dad
but you're not going to lie to us
you're just gonna let her okay now
you're all welcome
I thought my life would be fixed
the kick wasn't the problem
and he stopped focusing on what was
behind
he started looking at what was right in
front of me
oh touch and chill not kidding
dismissed
are you Nichols except you Nichols
fight me I need you to stay a little
longer
uh just like Danny
Knuckles bleed
it's solid Stone
I'll break my hand
it will heal in time for the tournament
s
[Music]
I'm coming home
you will go home
when the lesson is over
oh no
break it you must use all your power oh
punch through it
are you even trying
oh
no God
[Music]
something is holding you back
the stone the stone is holding her back
you act strong
that's not true your feelings have made
you weak weak no you care more about
this boy than your own dojo
I broke up with him because of this JoJo
you [ __ ]
oh
there must have been a hard decision
has never broken the stone before Oh
[ __ ] once upon a time there was a
Dwarven Monk and he was a member of the
most badass Guild in all the land he
made a pact
with a silver-haired king
who would usurp the leader the king
struck the monk down
again and again and
the Monk's just scared
oh
I'm sorry
that's great thanks for nothing
[Music]
it's traumatized and fears for his life
so hard
for her to admit wishing you
and now it's up to you to decide what to
do about it
time to be her best friend Sam all of
Branch it's a good point man Joseph's a
good dude man that's putting him mildly
I just feel bad he doesn't have a date
yeah that Kokomo chick was a Million
Miles Away
but you mean
I was trying to think of her name
does she know how you feel
[Music]
oh
Unforgivable
oh punishing yourself you've done all
you can to make up for what you did back
then
look man she's the reason you're here
she went after you
maybe now it's your turn to go after her
no way
oh
who's he on a date with
oh with his with Julia Macchio
is that with his sister yeah I knew it
are you dating my sister Louie
I was going
oh
what are you doing you can do better
than him oh
get Marissa Tomei back for the first
time in a long time it's not any of the
karate people causing the fight and
Terry silver had nothing to do with it
the reason I'm calling is
I would like to see you when I come home
I am glad I came here comical
but uh I make a one big mistake
oh
I should have taken you with me
my man okay bye
that's perfect
that's how you leave a voicemail
sure
other ones can be a little sketch like
me
what are you doing here
oh my God what happened
like you care
you're right I don't
know if you're having problems with
Cobra Kai
you'll be willing to listen
ah go to the hospital
can't afford that
you talk to Stingray he basically
admitted it was silver who assaulted him
in the old Dojo but he's too afraid to
go to the police I knew silver was
involved problem is we can't prove it
what happened at the old Dojo maybe we
can surveillance
surveillance
that's right
your younger students show more
potential Lee for example you really
think Devin Lee has a shot at winning
the Sakai takai she's still pretty green
youth is not a liability
it is the greatest power
she feeds off it drinks the blood
if we're successful
Cobra Kai will go on forever and what if
your enemies managed to cross the stream
I'm not gonna let that happen
oh my God
oh he paid off the driver they are not
buckled up hope he didn't pay off the
driver
no no no I'm sorry okay I should have
told you about Ness
rising up
back on the street is this the wrong
limo
you almost there oh no yeah bye now yo
Luke you see where the party limit went
oh no right here wait if he's not
driving
who's driving
I think driver does not want us to leave
all right let's get some seat belts
going
[Music]
this is ridiculous
God damn it tear yourself
don't end there oh my God where is he
driving them to
going to Canada or Mexico gonna meet the
girl's father tells dad Terry silver
hired McGill's dad
kidnap them
Thomas Ian Griffith
before
and John Carpenter's vampires he was
really good in that too
oh he's in Vampire yeah he's the main
vampire
cool all right Greg since you didn't get
to say anything you wanted to say in
last episode why don't you leave it off
all right first Easter egg go for it man
there are things about Karate Kid too
that are constantly referenced that
chosen keeps talking about
um I had the Tiger Rocky III
uh
uh thomasine Griffith from vampires
movie
so yeah was it really a matrix right it
really was I'm telling you it was
I know great the question my history the
only thing that was missing was the
security guard saying holy [ __ ] yeah and
then chosen shooting up the club
doing a cool flip while propeller heads
plays yeah uh yeah I thought this was a
great penultimate episode
um I like the setup I remember where
it's going I felt bad for Stingray poor
guy
I understood for the first like it's
it's easy to kind of loathe him and be
like God you're pathetic
and then when you see it in this
perspective of ah yeah you know I'd be
pretty scared too to kind of go with the
truth if I've been presented with this
option like you can delight yourself in
the lies and whatever but at the end of
the day it is scary to come clean up for
the sacrifice of the goodies but for the
fear that this man might kill you lion
literally murder you is a is a
terrifying feeling because I remember
how
um harsh and and uh
just uh freaking evil it was when Terry
SilverStar beat him up that was like a
really unpleasant scene and to be
reminded of such a moment oh yeah yeah
okay I get where he's coming from
uh but really you know chosen chosen's
like the star of this episode so anyway
it's chosen it's like the star of the
Season he's he's so amazing he's so he's
incredible yeah I know you're all about
Thomas Ian Griffith no chosen chosen
chosen's right like right there too but
chosen is the the amount of layers we've
got to explore we've chosen this season
have been so fun we've do like so many
different variations of this character
um from you know like being super Stern
to having a little more of a humorous
side to being a fish out of water and
now to see his more drunk sociable side
and getting his romantic side I don't
know it's just I'm really loving
everything with chosen I think he's he's
such a powerful addition to the show you
know and like what he was announced to
come back for Cobra Kai when I Revisited
Karate Kid 2. I was like I haven't
really that excited for this guy to come
back and then like he's such a great
character he's he's awesome yeah he's
he's amazing in every moment he's in and
now I I can't really imagine the show
moving forward without him like it it
seems like it would be a disservice to
the show to remove him moving forward
yeah
um because yeah not even the marketing
leading up to this prepared us for for
that and uh
Andrew yeah go ahead go before I do the
easter eggs and references I think for
me I agree with everything well I I
think everyone knows what I think of him
I'm not gonna go there
um I really love what Peyton List is
doing Tori Nichols uh and what they're
doing with her character as well and
also I thought it was really cool or
interesting rather seeing Sam when she
saw in her apartment for the first time
just the living parameters of what you
know Tori has to go through on a
day-to-day basis and then her seeing her
mom sick in the bed it gave Sam A New
Perspective on what Tori has to deal
with Day by Dave away from karate and
you know just gave her a whole new
perspective on what she feels towards
Tori I mean obviously there's always
going to be that animosity and that
anger towards her just from everything
that they've dealt with since they first
met in season two where they believe it
was at the Encino club and she accused
him of stealing from her mom and
everything that went from there I'm sure
you're right about that yeah but
again it's again I like that they they
chose to go that way with uh seeing Sam
you know just okay this is not you know
this is not what I was expecting to see
when I walked in here I mean I wasn't
expecting you know the Ritz Carlton
Hotel or something when I walked in here
but this is definitely different than
what I was expecting from you know I I
don't
I thought that was a great great idea
and uh I like that interaction that
scene we got and then when she you know
the concerns she had even though I know
you were like she doesn't care about her
you know when when she uh saw the the
bruising on her hand you know there was
there was quite concern and I like too
what Robbie and or rather Miguel you
know said to Sam like hey like look like
it was like you've never been in Cobra
Kai you don't know what they do to you
how they corrupt you and all that and
you know the fact that she was hiding
the sin and that she came out with it
was the important thing and I thought
again there's just some really great
character interactions in this uh in
this episode I love it was a really good
pivot to where we're gonna uh end and
especially that Cliffhanger was really
like almost a literal Cliffhanger yeah
literally yeah I hope it doesn't end
like uh did in Karate Kid for uh Daniel
when he got literally thrown off that
cliff on his bike by Johnny and the gang
but we shall see in the next episode I
hope it doesn't end like that but uh
getting to the Easter eggs the
references and trivia I'm sure I'm gonna
miss a couple but I wish I had a pen and
paper because there was something in
this one chosen mentioned the castle
that him and komiko used to hide at I
believe that was the castle that the
ending of Karate Kid Part Two where the
final battle happened uh was they talked
about the weighted thing that happened
in Karate Kid Part Two obviously we saw
Tori breaking her Knuckles obviously
that's a reference to Daniel breaking
his knuckles and Karate Kid Part three
as well as Chris and Karate Kid Part Two
breaking his knuckles uh breaking the
glass with Mr Miyagi and also with
Daniel fighting uh hitting the wooden
thing with Mike Barnes face on it and uh
if there are any more when John is
talking I will let you guys know cut him
off I will just cut him off
yes he's flowing just interrupting right
when he's fun but I'm sure I'm sure
there were a couple others that I am
missing but yeah that's all I can think
of it this very second embarrassing
there should be more stuff it should be
littered with them and the Matrix one
and also obviously we got a Julia machio
back uh Daniel or uh Ralph Macho's real
life daughter who everyone put in the
comments section of that episode that
she was on uh did you guys know that was
Julia Macho Ralph Macchio's uh daughter
I'm like yeah we talked about that in
that episode we know guys
yeah she's hotter than Ralph Want You
She's a little hotter than Ralph Matthew
we're off Macho pretty hot
oh and uh Daniel did say uh to chosen uh
in his racist tone I will get it for you
that's what uh chosen said to Daniel for
getting him the drink when they were in
uh Okinawa uh with komiko and also
obviously Daniel was being racist well
according to you we were just having fun
no no you're being serious uh and also
too with the six bucks and with the six
blocks of Ice uh that chosen mentioned
with uh Daniel obviously he did that in
part two as well so there's a couple
others but John go ahead I'll interrupt
you at some point yeah
I'll uh try and fill in the margins for
you guys this is this is a lovely
wonderful and very tense episode and I'm
very worried for that baby I really hope
nothing happens to that baby because
they let slip that they're having a baby
and now Terry crease knows explicitly
when he didn't know about the babies I'm
very worried
about Johnny and Carmen's baby but I
thought this was yeah this was another
terrific episode Another terrific uh you
know piece of this puzzle mounting I
don't know they've drawn a really rich
and interesting tapestry I think
especially looking over the past several
seasons of these characters like you
said like stingray oh this guy is easy
to laugh at easy to hate or you know
Tori I remember in past Seasons it's
like we were all kind of saying like I
know they're gonna humanize her butt I
kind of hate you but they I think they
an episode like this kind of exemplifies
just how well they have done over time
at allowing you to have these feelings
about characters allowing the characters
to act certain ways and then
allowing you to naturally come to their
Humanity with your protagonists and I
think that they do nicely to have good
conversations like I liked uh that
moment where Robbie goes it's it's a bit
of a you could read it as a bit of a
random happening in the middle of this
episode but the way Robbie goes in and
basically says you know hey guys I
shouldn't I shouldn't have just bailed
out on all of you and not said anything
I should have let you all know why I was
doing this and maybe giving you the
chance to come with me or something like
that and then at that moment with Miguel
and uh and uh Sam after they talk to
Stingray like At first I was like oh
we're gonna do this now but then the way
that conversation unfolded it was very
natural very real and felt like yeah if
we are going to help the bigger picture
we also gotta dislodge some of this you
know smaller more micro personal stuff
and uh and yeah I just thought they did
nicely to
address all that with nuance and then
put you in a party scenario where you're
like I just want everybody to have a
nice night and I just have a feeling
something Terrible's gonna have time to
interrupt John do it he said the word
party party chosen said party time I
think we all know that reference party
time from uh the mass
1964.3 uh yeah yeah no party time was
obviously Karate Kid part three when uh
silver increase who you just called
Terry crease I believe I'd heard you say
earlier
um oh chosen left a voicemail which is a
reference to Spider-Man 2 when uh I knew
I was forgetting one MJ can you name any
other movies with voicemails or is it
just that one I believe that's the only
movie with a voicemail are there
voicemails and you've got mail or is
that only emails only email uh with
negate the whole purpose so when there
were emails I wouldn't know that when
there were emails and other seasons of
Cobra Kai that was the reference that
you've got oh okay yeah yeah and the
nightclub uh is a reference to the movie
um Stuck on You by The Fairly Brothers
got it it was a good that's a good one
and yeah uh one thing also I didn't want
to mention that I didn't talk about
earlier is the conversation that
happened between Miguel and Sam I kind
of thought they were brushing over it a
little bit I know there were other ex
you know things that were happening in
the episode but I'm like I'm not gonna
talk about this but I was glad that they
did address it in regards to Miguel's
Scissorhands you know with that uh that
kiss that he had with that that woman at
the uh at the party
I thought his perspective was actually
interesting at this you know where he
was like I mean you said you wanted to
be friends and you didn't want to do
karate and then next thing I know you're
at a all world karate tournament and
then you're getting mad at me for
kissing a girl it's like it just felt
like a very humanizing moment in a real
world conversation like yeah it's true
like like Sam what do you want like I
mean I I get it she was ready to tell
him how she felt but of course Very you
know is very formulaic where perfect
timing she came in right at the at the
moment he was kissing you know a woman
but again I I actually did like that
conversation I thought you know was very
well told by Mikhail well that's one of
the great things about this show is
they're good at balancing those
quintessential movie moments Those
cheese moments of oh of course you would
walk in right now but with a real
believable you know the mess of just
being human making mistakes and not
knowing quite how to communicate them to
other people you know like the way that
conversation when they actually do have
it goes down I was like I expect the
show not to go down the Silly cliche
route of like them having a big blow up
and everything gets worse but you know
like they could have done that and they
chose not to and true and it's it's that
I think that tempers the the cheese well
so then you can forgive it for being a
little convenient because then we get
good character but yeah no that's true
yeah
I think
that
this show should end
with a 30 years Flash Forward
two Dimitri and Yasmin having children
Andrew please I have a very specific
pitch in mind
but that could be mentioned as a
throwaway line so we know what's up to
them uh it should be a 30 years Flash
Forward to Johnny's son
and Terry shows up
try to kill him
and then he does the crane kick
and kills Terry silver
and then the FBI comes in an arrest
Terry for
tax evasion
all right the arrest Terry's dead body
any inspiring writers out there Greg has
laid the foundation for you just giving
story credit 15 minutes
last 15 minutes 30 years Flash Forward
Alaska
that's where they're living
Off the Grid have one of those scenes
it's going to be interesting
off I'd love to see the show end on that
now it's too cold for karate in Alaska
pretty
I almost like that as much as was your
Fast and Furious Transformers I did them
almost as good
all right guys all right let's watch the
finale
patron of the day show first
Michael B Michael Miguel my man we have
looked up your name on Urban Dictionary
so you know what's going to get crazy up
in here here we go from the Hebrew name
Mikhail meaning who is like God
uh yeah I would say so you're very
christ-like in your content yeah this is
yeah this is urban it's just getting
funny and dirty just wait crazy just
wait this is a rhetorical question
implying no person is like God
uh it's an accurate statement so your
name's a lie uh yeah it's a question
your name is a question who is like I
said your name is a rhetorical question
that's that's frustrating oh don't worry
it's gonna get fun up in here it's fun
and nasty Michael is one of the seven
archangels in Hebrew tradition and the
only one identified as an archangel in
the Bible
cool oh you pervert you sicko you uh put
that thing away Michael's just to put
your your kickstand back in your it's
it's in your bike it's a metaphor for
for for Michael's Big Wang for how yeah
it's the artist
wow Urban Dictionary
theological I I don't
anyway check out Omni media there's
reactions and reviews too
[Music]